is discord trying to screw you out of a
class action is better help offering
fake therapy let's find out
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to litigate
the terms of service for discord and
better help if you have a suggestion for
the next legal topic please leave it
below and if you disagree with me please
be sure to leave your comment in the
form of an objection but remember to
keep things civil because Stella the
legal beagle carries the gavel of
justice and she's not afraid to use it
in the comments section all right let's
think like a lawyer today we're talking
TOS --is Terms of Service
these are usually really dry boring
contracts but there are two particular
tio asses in the news recently those
from discord and better help and not in
a good way there are two issues that I
want to discuss today number one is
discord arbitration clause and class
action waiver legal and number two does
better helps terms mean that they are
offering sham services what is a TOS or
term of service a term of service is
that long contract that you sign when
you sign up for a website or some
software that governs your relationship
and I'm sure everyone here has read the
entire contract before clicking accept
and then going on to use a website right
right no one reads all of the Terms of
Service but despite the fact that you
may not read it the term of service
still governs the relationship between
you and that website or the software
that you are using the term of service
will do a couple of things number one
they set out the rules by which you must
abide if you are going to continue to
use their software or service and number
two they also provide the obligations
that the company is going to give to you
in return for you being a user of that
website or software but a term of
service doesn't have to have any
particular terms it can lay out rules
that can create obligations on behalf of
the website it can create obligations on
behalf of the user to the website or it
can be simply a disclaimer that
disclaims any kind of warranty or any
kind of relationship at all between the
website itself and the users of that
website to try and get
of liability as between the users and
the website itself today we're gonna
talk about two TOS in particular those
from a company called discord which
provides VoIP or VoIP services and the
second from a company called better help
which provides online teletherapy
services to its users the first TOS I
want to discuss comes from discord
what's controversial here is that a few
days ago discord created a new term in
their TOS that is a class action waiver
ostensibly it prevents any user of the
discord services from filing a
class-action lawsuit and instead
requires the those users to go into
what's called binding arbitration
instead of using the courts so let's
take a step back first and talk about
what is a class action a class action is
a way of aggregating harms that are so
small that no one would ever file suit
as a result of that particular harm
there was a movement that started in the
states and then was governed mostly by
federal law which allows a bunch of
really small claimants to aggregate
their claims together now there are a
ton of requirements rule 23 of the
Federal Rules of Civil Procedure
requires that you have to have things
like an adequate class that must be
ascertainable there must be enough of
those claims to make it basically
worthwhile to file a class-action suit
those claimants must have a common claim
and that the class representatives must
have a claim that's typical of those
common claims of the class and there are
other requirements like the
representative counsel must be adequate
and a number of other things but the
bottom line is that a class-action
lawsuit is a way for one or a handful of
class members to basically put forward a
case on behalf of the entire class of
people so instead of just filing suit on
behalf of yourself as you would in a
normal lawsuit you're filing suit with
the help of your attorneys on behalf of
hundreds potentially thousands and
sometimes even millions of people and by
aggregating all of those small things
together you create a financial
incentive to go forward with that
a class-action lawsuit historically has
been done by the Attorney General but
now for the most part it's done by
private individuals so you might ask
yourself why would someone file a
class-action lawsuit
well it's partially the people
themselves and it's partially the
attorneys the attorneys are going to get
a large cut of the payout often you are
aggregating so many of these small
claims together that a class-action
lawsuit is often a bet the company case
so that if the company lost it and had
to pay out what the plaintiff is
claiming it might bankrupt the entire
company I've handled a ton of class
actions before usually defending very
innocent companies from scurrilous
plaintiffs attorneys just trying to make
a buck but you know I've also been a
member of a class before and I've gotten
one of those $2 checks from being a
class member in a very small
class-action recovery so I see it both
ways I understand the need for companies
to have a punitive action taken against
them when they've clearly done something
wrong but I've also seen plaintiffs
attorneys out there just in it to get
the attorneys fees from that big pool of
money so discord changed its term of
service and now requires a class action
waiver and a private arbitration clause
which means that instead of being able
to use the regular court system and
using a class action in the regular
court system they force you into private
arbitration where you're not able to
file a class-action lawsuit now
arbitration sounds scary but arbitration
is really just an informal version of
court the main difference is that
generally both parties have to hire the
arbitrator so instead of regular court
work you're not paying for the salary of
the judge in arbitration both sides
usually have to pay for the arbitrator's
salary so it's more informal you can set
whatever rules you want as long as
they're agreed upon by both sides and
you have to pay for the arbitrator's
time now discord came out with a
statement defending their decision to
include these arbitration agreements
saying that class actions can be very
bad they're used by attorneys to get
huge fees and they take those fees out
of the class recovery and that people
often get really small rewards they
don't care about and they often just
throw away those checks now all of those
they
are in fact true but you could see them
as features not bugs again often if
people weren't able to aggregate all
these claims they never would have been
incentivized to file the suit in the
first place and believe me lawyers don't
like to work for free so unless there is
a big enough incentive they won't handle
those cases I've handled both court
cases and arbitrations and I can't say
for a fact that one is necessarily
better than the other arbitration is
almost certainly faster because courts
are really backed up arbitration gives
you individualized attention whereas in
court the judge is spreading his or her
time between hundreds or thousands of
different cases at any given time
whereas an arbitration you might get one
two three retired judges who probably
aren't handling that many cases
arbitration is generally way more
expensive because both parties have to
pay the arbitrator's hourly and I think
the last arbitrator I had to hire was
$900 an hour I think they can charge
these fees because they have a certain
pedigree from being ex judges and really
knowing what they're talking about
and good arbitrators are really
important to hire but I can't say that
an arbitration necessarily favors the
defendant which is something that I see
people saying all the time
I think people usually say that because
of the cost but again arbitrators
themselves are just as good as regular
judges so I don't think that they're
going to be biased in favor of the
defendant necessarily here in particular
though the fees issue isn't as bad as it
normally would be in dis cords TOS they
say specifically that they will pay for
any fees over what it would cost to file
in court unless the arbitrator finds
that the case itself was filed
frivolously so one of the main
complaints that you might have about
arbitration in the consumer context
where what consumer is going to want to
fight $100 case if they're gonna have to
pay out hundreds of dollars in fees to
the arbitrator well here discord is
already agreeing to pay for the fees of
the arbitrator all you have to pay for
are the normal filing fees that it would
cost to file suit now those themselves
can be in the hundreds of dollars but
still that's nothing compared to paying
an arbitrator $900 an hour for
dozens if not hundreds of hours now
interestingly this actually might give
you more leverage against discord
because since discord is on the hook to
pay for these arbitrators services this
court might rather just settle the case
for a nominal fee instead of having to
go through expensive arbitration where
they're paying for not only their own
attorneys but also the fees of the
arbitrator as well so ironically this
term of service may actually give some
leverage to the consumer but on the
other hand the TOS does clearly require
you to waive your class action right so
you can't file a class-action lawsuit
now the big benefit as we discussed is
being able to aggregate all these small
claims that no one would individually
want to file suit over and instead it
requires you to file an individual suit
on your own basis so you lose the
benefit of having this litigation if
there is litigation taken care of for
you by some other attorney and some
other representative plaintiff and
frankly it's a relatively small chance
that it's going to be relevant to you
and even smaller chance that it's a
recovery that you care about but it
certainly does prevent anyone from
taking punitive action against discord
for a violation of the law and some
people think that lawsuits and
especially class-action lawsuits are
created specifically for their punitive
action to make sure that companies stay
in line even when the recoveries are
very very small on an individual basis
so at the end of the day this is a mixed
bag for users of discord it's not as
scary as it first seems but there's
actually some good things in there it
allows you to go through arbitration
which can be much faster than courts and
much more informal on dis cords dime
however you do give up the right to file
a class-action lawsuit and you may lose
out on some small checks that would have
been done by class-action attorneys and
class-action plaintiffs in some other
universe so there are some good things
and some bad things in this new discord
TOS but the question is is it legal
well recent Supreme Court does in fact
allow these class action waivers
starting in 2011 in the AT&T versus
concepción case and recently reaffirmed
this year in epic vs. Lewis and Ernst &
Young versus Morris class-action wave
are enforceable and companies can force
you into private arbitration so you
might not like it but it's probably
legal so let's move on to the second
term of service that from the company
called better help my understanding is
that better help is an online platform
that links online therapists with
consumers I've never used better help
unlike a lot of people on YouTube I am
NOT sponsored by better help but I can
certainly see the benefit of being able
to just dial up a therapist using Skype
instead of having to drive you know over
to a therapist and see them in person
maybe that's a good service I don't know
but what I can tell you is that there is
a huge controversy brewing over better
helps term of service as of a few weeks
ago the better helped EOS implied that
they didn't check the credentials or the
background of all the therapeutic
professionals that they used to link up
between consumers and the therapists so
let's look at this disclaimer in the
original Terms of Service it seems
pretty clear that the old TOS says that
better help was not obligated to check
out the background or the credentials of
the therapists that they use now even as
originally written this is a floor this
is a disclaimer of liability it's a
statement that there is no obligation
but it's not a statement that better
help was absolutely not checking on
their professionals
according to better help themselves they
were checking on the backgrounds and
credentials of their therapists but they
didn't want to be on the hook for Mis
statements by those therapists and they
didn't want to be obligated to undertake
that even though that they were
generally providing that service Phil
DeFranco did an entire video about this
all linked to that down below and from
what I can piece together he seems to
get things more or less right from that
Terms of Service there's this question
that pops up of okay are you just
allowing anyone to say that they're a
counselor right because that language is
concerning and is completely alien to my
understanding of how they go and vet
these people so from here I then reached
out to our contact at better health we
ended up being connected with the
founder of better help alone Matassa he
gave me a statement where at one point
he talked about the terms and
additions and questions say the terms
and conditions document typically
provides the legalese that defines the
extent of liability and mitigates legal
risks associated with such platform we
will be revising the terms and
conditions document so it more closely
matches the vetting process we currently
conduct this is kind of standard
legalese that you'll see in a TOS like
this it's about preventing legal
liability it is not a statement that
better help was actively turning a blind
eye to their therapist and my
understanding is that in a reaction to
this controversy better help has revised
their term of service to more accurately
reflect what they actually do and now
they are taking on the affirmative legal
burden associated with those actions but
even as originally written it doesn't
seem like this was much to do about
anything
additionally PewDiePie who seems to have
an axe to grind in this particular
controversy was aggrieved by better
helps disclaimer of warranty pointing
out that better help stated that they
don't stand by they're professionals now
this is called a disclaimer this is very
very common in fact I would bet that in
the TOS of almost every website that you
interact with there is a disclaimer that
says that they disclaim any warranty for
the services that they provide and
really it's not surprising that better
help would be any different better help
is basically just a platform that links
up online therapists to patients so it's
not surprising that the platform would
want to disclaim liability from the
independent contractors that it
contracts with this is pretty standard
for any kind of platform in almost any
website that you do business with for
example my guess is that if you hire a
plumber through Angie's List
Angie's List is not going to guarantee
the work of that plumber this kind of
disclaimer is very very common and it's
certainly nothing to freak out about
similar terms are probably behind every
website that you visit and govern every
relationship with any platform that you
use so I can't say whether you should go
to better help for therapy services but
I can say you should not go to PewDiePie
for legal advice do you agree leave your
objections in the comments and until
next time I'll see you in court